It's not like a requirement,
but once you become a single mom,
you start having to acquire shit you've never had before.
And one of my favorite things that I've had to start collecting
since becoming a single mom
has been Fucking Power Tools.
This one specifically is my fucking favorite.
Do you know how fucking powerful you feel
chopping shit down with an actual chainsaw?
Obviously, that's not how you use it.
Use it safely. It feels so good,
and it is actually very useful.
There's a ton of weeds that girl.
That are super fucking huge and fat,
and I chop them down. This shit is just.
I feel so good. It feels so good.
It feels so good. It feels so good.
So I'm just saying,
if you're a single mom and you have shit you have to do,
don't be afraid of the fucking power tools.
It's actually quite exhilarating.
And you get to, like, get your fucking tools.
I love it.
There are huge Black Friday and Cyber Monday deals coming up,
so should you want to start a collection of your own,
you can follow the link right here. That's all I'm saying.